We are an unusual couple you know oh i
don't think that was ever in question
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new avengers Wandavision video they made
a big announcement this past week so i'll explain
what's going on marvel also released a really cool
new x-men trailer that i'll play in a second
too but if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we are getting
Wandavision episodes later this year in 2020 i
will be doing videos for all those of course so
we'll do a disney plus giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and let me know what
kind of easter eggs you want to see on Wandavision
but part of the reason why we talk about x-men
and Wandavision together is because there's
going to be some new x-men marvel phase four
stuff happening on the Wandavision series they're
going to be using it to set up a lot of things
mutants and x-men and the mcu is just part of that
but just starting with the big stuff first number
five if you didn't see the news disney released a
new disney plus trailer and there was a bunch
of upcoming mandalorian season 2 episode stuff
in it because that just premiered but there was
not any mention or any footage of Wandavision
earlier this year they did release a coming soon
trailer quote unquote for fall in winter 2020
there was a bunch of Wandavision stuff during
that saying that it was coming during 2020 so
the saying that Wandavision is coming before the
end of 2020 but it's not coming in november so you
do the complex calculus equations to figure this
out and it sounds like it's a soft confirmation
that Wandavision will be premiering in december
like they originally intended i know everyone
wants to know what day Wandavision episode 1 is
actually going to release typically in the past
disney has only released one major series at a
time without any overlap so they've only had star
wars disney plus series so far but they waited to
drop all the clone wars season 7 episodes until
after the mandalorian season 1 episodes had been
released so the logic being that they keep people
subscribed to disney plus longer if they keep
releasing new content and it's easier to do that
if they just stretch it out as much as possible so
unless they want to overlap the mandalorian season
2 finale this year with Wandavision episode 1,
Wandavision would not premiere till december 25th
christmas day because it's falling on a friday
this year and they usually release new episodes
on fridays but if you remember last year there
was a bit of an overlap between star wars rise of
skywalker and the mandalorian season 1 episodes
around the christmas holiday so what they did
is is they just shifted the mandalorian
episodes to a different part of the week
so marvel might wind up doing the same thing
where they release Wandavision episode one
on tuesday or wednesday before christmas day
either way no matter when they start releasing
episodes during december the finale wouldn't drop
till january so we will have content from disney
plus thankfully through january there were some
rumors that marvel and disney were so thirsty
for content because of the way the virus shut
everything down this year like we didn't get any
new marvel movies it was crazy it was the first
time since marvel phase one that that happened
so the rumor was as they increased the original
number of Wandavision episodes from the original
six but it's just a rumor so we could be getting
more than six episodes of Wandavision and as for
falcon and winter soldier they finished filming
that a while ago and the hope is that they'll
release those episodes after the Wandavision
finale maybe with a couple weeks in between so
that'd be like late february march release date
hopefully they'll release the full falcon and
winter soldier trailer before the end of the year
and attach the release date to that but talking
more about Wandavision x-men mutants in the mcu
and marvel phase four marvel just released a brand
new x-men trailer that's a new redesigned version
of x-men the animated series so here's the full
trailer for that crank the nostalgia up to 11. the
world tonight is in the grip of a terrible crisis
those unfortunate mistakes of nature are
running wild how could you register her
with that mutant control agency as
if she were some sort of criminal
this is professor xavier's school for the
gifted all of us here are mutants like yourself
we x-men learn something very special here jubilee
how to control our mutant powers for the benefit
of mankind but then why do people hate us
your violence will solve nothing
we must use our special gifts to bring peace
to mankind if we fail there will be a civil war
better that we die on our
feet than live on our knees
the way they cut that is just meant to feel like
a modern drama series because most of the trailers
they released for the 90s animated shows were way
more quick and dirty marvel has just been hyping
up all the x-men content on disney plus lately
because they're trying to prime everyone for new
mcu x-men debut in the next couple of years
they even rebranded a big section of their
marvel movie content as marvel legacy for all
the fox marvel films but notice it's only the
fantastic four films in the x-men films there's
no deadpool in here anywhere so take that for what
you will theorycraft all you want deadpool right
now in his current rated r form is being treated
like he's in his own self-contained universe of
continuity but they're letting the deadpool 3
team and ryan reynolds do anything they want
to with that movie for the most part reportedly
they're also signing him to a mega cameo
deal to sort of stanley cameo his way through
upcoming marvel phase 4 marvel phase 5 movies but
if they wind up signing that deal no idea what his
first cameo would be or which movie that would
happen in my assumption when it comes to stuff
like that is that full-blown crossover wouldn't
happen till tail end marvel phase 4 or during
marvel phase 5 which right now per the schedule
would be somewhere between 2022 and 2023 so still
a long ways off a little while ago he did a big
interview talking about the status of deadpool
3 giving a big update on the movie and talked
about actively trying to get himself banned from
disney so i'm hoping it's released sooner than
later but i know disney's super excited about it
they bought it from fox where i used to where i
used to work uh and uh yeah and here we go yeah
is deadpool also fox deadpool yeah what was
fox and then now it is in the hands of marvel
uh over there at disney yeah and what and
and can can can those worlds be combined
or we don't know i don't i see so much i see
infinite possibility in either version you know if
deadpool were to be in the marvel comic universe
i think or the marvel cinematic universe rather
i think it would be explosive and amazing and
what a sandbox to play in if deadpool continued
to get to just do his own thing and be his own
thing uh also just like infinite possibility
and you know i mean we have you do you make that
your own thing i mean that is i i do i write it
i write it with two other guys rhett reese and
paul wernick who are geniuses and amazing in
you know in so many ways and and we just have so
much fun we actually write it all right in here
in this room um where i'm sitting and um and we
just have the best time doing it together so we
hope that we're going to there's a lot more to
a lot more story to tell so we hope we get to do
that soon there's a couple jokes that you told me
about i won't say now because i don't want to ruin
the third one but it didn't make it to the second
one but it was really really funny thing that was
going on i was like oh they'll never let you
do that yeah you could fill a gymnasium with
some of the jokes that got cut out of deadpool
one and two that would get us all arrested or
turned into some sort of disney liquid so when we
talk about mcu x-men stuff you have the deadpool 3
stuff that's going on that they're trying to
integrate and fold in then separately you have all
the Wandavision mutant stuff but all the new x-men
stuff they're doing on Wandavision begins with the
way they're telling the multiverse storyline
or starting the multiverse chaos that's going
to inform the rest of the marvel phase 4 movies
through doctor strange 2 called multiverse of
madness that's basically going to be when things
peak out and doctor strange and scarlet witch team
up to stop all the chaos that she helped create
but during the Wandavision series scarlet witch
lives in the pocket alternate reality that we
see in the trailer tv like dimension whatever
you want to call it where she has what looks
like her chaos level magic ability to change
reality on a whim and because we see that
house of m easter egg the meson du ma prix
wine which basically means house of contempt or
says house of m just like that story line that
reality eventually starts to crumble and maybe
she finds a way to save her children and bring
them back to the main mcu dimension with her where
eventually they could come back in future young
avengers related projects or other disney plus
series there will be another Wandavision trailer
sometime this month but probably not till after
all the election craziness dies down this week
i will be doing marvel videos and more mandalorian
season 2 videos this week my mandalorian season 2
episode 2 video we'll also be posting on friday
leave all your video requests in the comments
below for any marvel or x-men related stuff that
you want me to do or even any mandalorian stuff
everyone click here for my full mandalorian
season 2 episode 1 video and click here for my
brand new thor 4 avengers video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!